let me let me welcome you here today
this is a very very very special special
day and I want to thank you for for
joining us it really gives me a great
great amount of pride to have the honor
of introducing one of our own who his
the cover of his book ended up in my end
basket and I read the cover and I was
just totally blown away and like even we
have amongst us we have someone who has
this capability
well actually truth be known I was not
surprised because we have a group of
really really extraordinarily talented
people one of our challenges is that we
we need to find ways to have our people
better exploit and take advantage of
their of their talents and that's a lot
of what we've been trying to do over the
last last couple of years there are
there are two things about about this
experience that I would like to take a
moment to to reflect on the and the
first is that one needs to follow follow
your dream and to follow your your
talents and the other is to focus on own
leadership
those are things again that we that we
press our our departments and our
leaders to to do for us with respect to
following your dream our author our team
member has certainly certainly done that
I I can't help and I hope you will love
will bear with me but I can't help but
think of this mild-mannered reporter you
know and and we have this this
mild-mannered UC staffer and the loans
and receivable office by day but by
night
huh what is he doing okay he's writing
books that are respected by universities
the likes of Wisconsin and and Berkeley
let's say that's that's really really a
big deal
the other piece that is very very
important is leadership and what I want
to do is to read just a paragraph for
you because it links David's values and
the ones that we're trying to remote
here very very directly and the
paragraph is in the preference where he
is talking about what he's hoping that
we'll gain from this more important
still it is my hope that the reader who
has the patience to follow this account
from beginning to end will by debt of
the repeated examples be brought through
the to the sheer to share its
fundamental assumptions namely that the
circumstances in which the Franco
Persian War unfolded unfolded contradict
wholly and emphatically the
deterministic view of history the the
conviction that the fate of humankind is
beyond the influence of accident and
personal that is shaped by the forces
beyond the play of human personality on
the contrary these circumstances
encourage the view that things happen
because individuals and discoverable
people decide things and do them this is
what I think is at the essence of it
David Wetzel's book the duel of giants
and is at the core of everything that I
think David and I share in common that
we believe that we as individuals as is
demonstrated by the principles in
dueling Giants believe that we can
control our own destiny david has done
that he is demonstrating that day in and
day out and with that I would like to
present to you David Wetzel ah thank you
very much uh let me begin by saying what
a pleasure it is to be speaking in
Berkeley where my intellectual and
occupational roots lie and where the
projects I am about to describe was
conceived commenced and completed in
October 2001 the University of Wisconsin
press published a book on which I had
been working for more than six years a
duel of giants Bismarck
Napoleon the third and the origins of
the franco-prussian war as part of my
contract with the press I agreed to give
a series of readings of passages from
the book both here on campus and
elsewhere this is the third and last
reading that will be held it will differ
in content from that of its predecessors
this will become apparent to those of
you who have attended the other readings
but first I would like to begin by
formally thanking our associate vice
chancellor Ron Coley and especially the
indefatigable maid Garstang of his staff
for again providing me a forum this
afternoon
many of you must be wondering at least I
hope a few of you are what on earth
possessed someone to write a book on a
subject as obscure or seemingly obscure
as the franco-prussian war the question
is a fair one and I would like to begin
by trying to answer it my reasons for
writing on the franco-prussian war were
I think three first a personal reason
I'm a historian I love the past and
fascinated by it and particularly
attracted to those events I believed to
be of great importance but that have
over the years fallen into neglect and
the franco-prussian war certainly fits
that description in the summer of 1870
the Kingdom of Prussia and her German
allies totally destroyed the military
power of Imperial France for over 80
years
France the defeated power had laid down
the law in military matters to Europe
whereas Prussia only ten years before
had been the least of the continents
military powers within one month Prussia
established a military superiority and a
political supremacy that made the
unification of Germany under her
leadership a matter of course and the
only an alliance involving virtually
every
major power in the world would rest from
her half a century later in World War
one for those who thought in it for
those who witnessed it the
franco-prussian war was the emotional
experience of their generation much as
the Spanish Civil War was to an earlier
generation of the 20th century much as
the Vietnam War was to a later one my
own on both sides there was almost
immediately an outpouring of books
letters diaries journals all of them
thrilling to read today in cold print
and the more each side
insisted on the greatness and
significance of the franco-prussian war
the more this cleavage between the two
developed and took on the character of
being the most fundamental event of
their time a British historian Sir
Michael Howard has pointed out that it
is doubtful whether any War the American
Civil War the First World War
not excepting has been the object of
such concentrated study in proportion to
its length and its extent remember this
war was over in virtually one month
bibliography compiled in 1898 just 25
years after the war ended could lists
over 7,000 titles and the flood was to
continue unabated for a generation the
last forty years however have been
another matter no book
on the subject to which this is
addressed and that was to occupy the
attention of historians for so long a
time has appeared in English since 1962
as I write in the book
what started as a flood became in the
1940s or there abouts first the current
then a stream then a rivulet and finally
a dry creek my book in the first
instance made therefore be seen as an
attempt to fill an aching void and I
wrote it simply because it was addressed
to a subject on which there had been
nothing done in 40 years my second
reason for taking up the franco-prussian
war has to do with the sources of the
materials for the study are there in
abundance
I mentioned the printed sources most of
which almost all of which are available
right here on campus and the
incomparable holdings of the library
about half my book is that maybe two
thirds of it is based on the materials I
found and read there then there are the
unpublished sources the one secret
sources the archival sources that are
available in the capitals of the
countries concerned Berlin and Paris
certainly but also London Rome and
Vienna I only wish I had more time to
tell you about these sources and the
buildings in which their documents
repose where I'm thinking now vienna
elegant marble statues of the kings and
emperors and queens smile down agreeably
on the arriving visitor but it is of
course the sources that are the subject
of my fascination and magnificent
documents they
our beautiful compilations marvelously
indexed meticulously organized easy to
read easy to copy as I can attest from
my experience with them and with their
custodians for whom nothing was ever too
much during the course of the time my
researches were conducted my third
reason for taking up the franco-prussian
war had to do with the temper of the
times when my inquiry began the late
1980s and early 1990s especially those
incredible years from 1989 to 1991 were
times when dizzying and tumultuous
change shook the world that we knew and
left us with something we're still
trying to figure out the revolutions in
Czechoslovakian Hungary in the summer of
1989 the fall of the Berlin Wall in
November of that year the reunification
of Germany in October 1990 the Gulf War
in January 1991 the collapse of the
Soviet Union in December 1991 all these
made a watershed in the history of our
time and convinced me that a book on a
subject like the franco-prussian war
which after all affected Germany more
than any other country would find among
readers lay and professional alike a
greater receptivity than had previously
been the case so much uh for my reasons
for writing the book now what is it
about the book has two theses each of
which I believe is fairly simple the
first is that human agents matter in
that they are not the puppets of
overriding personalities of her
overriding forces beyond the play of
human personalities there are serious
scholars who contend that the
unification of Germany would have taken
place with or without this mark who
argue that Nazi policy in the 1930s and
1940s would have been the same with or
without Hitler who contend that the Cold
War would have ended much the way it
ended Gorbachev or no Gorbachev Reagan
or no Reagan who assert today that the
crisis in the Middle East can be
understood and comprehended apart from
the personalities of sharone or Arafat
know who reads my book can come away
from it and possibly think that of the
statesmen who took their countries into
the inferno that was the franco-prussian
war my second thesis is as I said that
the franco-prussian war was a great
event
in the history of Europe indeed in the
history of the world and that it has
consequences that reach down to the
present day
this will become apparent from the
readings now before I begin I'd like to
say just a word or two about a country
whose name I've already mentioned
because it might not be as familiar to
you as a historian of Germany 19th
century Germany would like to suppose
this country was Prussia what was
Prussia
well Prussia was a great power by 1870
the strongest power in Central Europe
she was as familiar to a European in
1870
Canada or Mexico or Japan would be to an
American today she'd bought a war
against Denmark in 1864 and won
she bought a war against Austria in 1866
and won as a result of that war she
gathered up all of the kingdoms the
duchies the principalities of Germany
north of the river mine and had put them
into a confederation under her control
capital Berlin indeed by 1870 you could
almost say that Germany was well on its
way to being United except that the
southern part four southern states had
yet to be brought in Prussia had a king
William the first and a prime minister
Otto von Bismarck who were these people
who ruled Prussia I'd like to begin by
telling you just a little bit about each
who was William the first William was a
staunch conservative by nature and by
conviction and he was a professional
soldier to his finger-tips he had served
with the Prussian army in the campaign
against Napoleon and he had commanded
the Prussian forces that had put down a
revolt in Baden in 1848 his interest in
German unity was stronger and deeper
than that of his predecessors and in May
18-49 he had written whoever wishes to
rule Germany must conquer it our whole
history shows that Prussia is destined
to lead Germany but the question is how
and when when he came to the throne at
the age of 63 William was set in his
ways and his mind was dominated by one
over
writing impression the army the liberal
politician Ludwik Bamberger put it
rather succinctly when he observed that
for William the state consisted of
soldiers and soldiers were the Kings no
words were ever truer William the first
blood the army with the passion for
which say perhaps through his ancestor
Frederick William the first it is
impossible to find a parallel in the
whole history of modern Germany for both
military efficiency came before
everything else for both everything else
had to be crossed off the agenda until
that had been taken care of Britain
never invisibly army as the agent
through which Pasha would pursue the
mastery of Germany but the plans through
the army that he had in mind could never
be launched let alone accomplished
without a political crisis as wrenching
as that through which England had passed
in the 1640s and whose outcome was every
bit as decisive for the future character
of the state to do its job
the army had to be reformed from head to
toe and for a long time first as Prince
of Prussia then his Regent when had been
thinking of little else so much was this
the case that King William fell into
conflict with the Parliament of Prussia
over this question of army reform
matters reached to crisis the climax in
1862 when the Parliament threatened to
shut off money for the Kings budget and
William at the point of abdication was
driven to summon to the Premiership of
Prussia his ambassador to France
the ruthlessly unorthodox otto von
bismarck the first of our two dueling
Giants I'd like to tell you a little bit
about Otto von Bismarck Bismarck was
born on 1 April 1815 at Shirin house in
the old mark of Brandenburg just east of
the elbe in appearance typical Jonker
estate in a district inhabited largely
by Protestants Bismarck himself was
unmistakably North German in appearance
and in Outlook in physique he was a big
man could he belong to what we would
call the modest gentry
he had a humble upbringing living on a
farm during plenty of the farm work
himself he did not have a particularly
distinguished career at the University
there was another extraordinary thing
about him until he became prime minister
almost dictator of Prussia in 1862 he
had never held political office he held
important diplomatic offices and from
these it seems he got his vision of the
world a few years before becoming
Minister president during the
revolutions of 1848 he was a violent
reactionary he thought the masses should
be shot down that one should return to
extreme conservatism or so he said no
great statesman has ever been more
solitary he lived to be 83 and in all
this long life he had hardly a friend
and the friends he had were Outsiders
like himself none from his own class of
Prussian Gentry or later on of German
nobility among other German statesmen no
friends at all he never visited other
Great Houses in fact he hated these they
wouldn't give him enough to eat or drink
thing it was only at his own house that
he could get those enormous hole hands
on the sideboard and the bottles of
champagne before dinner just because he
was thirsty and the bottle or two of
brandy afterwards and the eight or ten
Havana cigars that he smoked in the
course of an afternoon or evening
Bismarck seems to have grasped what was
going on in the world by solitary
meditation plodding along in those
planes of North Germany observing the
birds and the trees
brooding a great deal he was a
tremendous brooder his great strokes of
policy came after long solitary brooding
not after discussion with others and in
a lung long life of conflict he fought
himself most of all yet he also
possessed certain qualities of mind and
character and character that bewitched
his contemporaries and that undoubtedly
contributed to the success of his
statecraft his cutting wit delighted
dinner companions for decades once
turned to his voice thin and Reedy by
the way almost a false set up that of an
academic not of a man of action they
learned to watch him as if he were a
trapeze artist soaring through every
imaginable subject spinning flipping
hanging by his heels the quintessential
showman but we had a good opinion of
himself he was free of the kind of
personal vanity that made some of his
contemporaries ludicrous and that ruined
others though clever in dealing with
subordinates Bismarck as a rule observed
the core of the diplomatic code
diplomats do not lie to one another for
all these reasons foreign diplomats
enjoyed doing business with him and
frequently came to the point giving him
their full faith and trust
Bismark and william the first were not
the only permanent figures of the
franco-prussian relationship there was
one other whose role in the designing
and bringing about of the war was so
prominent and whose name will appear so
frequently in this account that he may
as well be identified at the outset this
was Napoleon the third emperor of the
French the second of our two dueling
giants Napoleon the third is worth
writing about seldom is so controversial
character held the sceptre of such power
in Europe Napoleon the third ruled
France for twenty-two years longer than
anyone else in her modern history yet
few men are more unknowable the more we
strip off his disguises the more new
disguises appear dreamer and realist
despot and Democrat conspirator and
Statesman maker of war and man at peace
creator and muddler one could go on
indefinitely all the greatest observers
of his time tried to penetrate his
secret
Tocqueville Marx Pierre Victor Hugo all
failed to make sense of him Bismarck
once called him us thinks without a
riddle rather he was a man of too many
riddles and riddles to which he himself
did not know the answer
everything about him baffles inquiry was
he the son of his father
if not then of whom he was a master of
concealment the correspondence of his
uncle Napoleon the first a new shadowy
was to live out his life runs 261
volumes that of Napoleon the third even
if it could be brought together with not
fill
Wallops key your legitimate son of
Napoleon the first and later foreign
minister to Napoleon the third one's
complained the ambassador's see my door
open but they walk right past it
they prefer in moments of sensitivity to
deal with the emperor alone
Napoleon the third talked endlessly to a
great variety of witnesses but the talk
like the smoke of the cigarettes of
which he was one of the first to favor
was vague and intangible it vanished
into the air leaving only a faint
romantic odor a thin cloud of mystery
all the same Napoleon the third was a
remarkable man his mind teem with
original often dangerous ideas that were
years ahead of his time his intellect
was enriched by great personal charm he
was vain maybe Moody but his Queen
Victoria once observed a prince among
men he was a beautiful speaker with a
ravishing voice and fine turn of phrase
there were political gifts behind the
cloud of phrases he was a skilled and
successful negotiator his reading during
long years of prison in his early life
has left him better educated than the
average ruler of the day taking up
chemistry he had written the treatise on
beet sugar competent enough to be
accepted seriously by the industry
though he appealed to the fears of the
middle class he was also a socialist and
a pamphlet on unemployment gained him
considerable those short-lived
popularity among workers he did more for
the poor than any other French statesman
before a sense he was like Benjamin
Franklin working on an economical stove
to improve their lot when he died
first and foremost his inventiveness
took a military event as an excellent
horseman as early as 1835 his manual on
artillery impressed the professionals
and a few years later he was busy
improving the French army musket
ironically in 1843 he was recommending
something similar to the Prussian system
of conscription that would ultimately
prove to be his ruin
and even as Bismarck's captivate
villains her after his defeat in the
franco-prussian war he soon busied
himself collecting material on Prussian
military organization nor was this all
at this point the Pauline the third was
also very sick suffering for some months
in the spring and summer of 1874 cold
fever tooth trouble and most
outstandingly from stone as well as from
the after-effects of the drugs
administered for the relief of these
miseries to mount a horse was tortured
and at times coherent thought impossible
stricken by these various dealers in
acute pain at times almost past
endurance he suffered daily the take of
telegrams and other official business
brought currently up to his apartments
and hoped as best he could but the
responsibilities that flowed from it all
by 1870 Napoleon the third was as was
plain to all who saw him a man gravely
weakened by age and by illness indeed a
shadow of his former self physically he
had the appearance of a man already dead
his left arm was paralyzed his eyes were
glazed and dull he moved with a slow
shuffling walk and was kept going only
by increasing doses
rocks sick and wracked by pain his
judgment the often still shrewd was
clouded by the language that had always
interrupted his rare moments of energy
the infrequent business of the members
of this government so obviously tired
the emperor that the ministers often
withdrew for sheer pity without even
having attempted to broach the subjects
about which they had come to see him
well we have our personalities Napoleon
the third on the one side Bismarck and
William the first on the other how did
these personalities these giants fall
into conflict with one another for that
I have to step back and try to set for
you some of the picture of Europe in the
late 1860's in 1868 there was a
revolution in Spain
Queen Isabella was dissolute she'd been
married to an impotent husband and took
the not surprising way out of having
many lovers who rather filled up the
royal palace in time the expenditure of
maintaining these lovers exasperated the
politicians there was a revolution and
Isabella was overthrown a Spanish
general became regent and there was a
republic but the Spanish rulers did not
wish to remain Republican the Spanish
crown was hocked around Europe this
raised a big problem they did not want
anyone who was too closely connected to
any great royal house Napoleon the third
ran one of his cousin's but there was a
general outcry that this would mean
putting France in power in Spain
then Bismarck had a bright idea rather I
should put a little differently Bismarck
had an idea and imposed it on the king
and his entourage more or less
successfully Spain was a Catholic
country there was in the House of
Hohenzollern the house of King William
the first depression a junior line that
was Catholic now here was a young man
Leopold of Hohenzollern sigmaringen but
all the qualifications he was a liberal
thought he could cooperate with Liberal
Germany he was a good though not overly
patriotic German moreover he was
Catholic beautiful answer wasn't it to
the problem and his brother was Prince
of Romania and had been nominated to
that post by Napoleon the third so there
was no reason to suppose that Napoleon
disliked Catholic Hohenzollerns
now Bismarck knew that there would be
French protests and he therefore meant
to rush the thing I should warn you that
there have been there's been a hundred
years of controversy and debate and it's
often said that Bismarck organized the
Hohenzollern candidacy to provoke the
French to war I think that he was
mistaken for reasons that I give in the
book the essential thing was to get
Leopold to Madrid on the throne of Spain
before the French could protest well it
so happens this marks little surprise
was never sprung in fact it blew up in
his face
on 3 July 1870 the news arrived in Paris
that Leopold was about to become king of
Spain a tremendous uproar
the Foreign Minister gramma whose name
you'll hear a lot of rushed into the
National Assembly and issued delivered a
fiery denunciation of William the first
in Prussia from the tribune of
Parliament grandma said Leopold must
withdraw or there will be war
at the same time instructions were drawn
up for benedetti the Prussian Minister -
the French minister to Prussia who was
on vacation at Anna's Benedetti was to
carry these instructions to William the
first Prussia who himself was on
vacation and to urge that Leopold step
aside in the interest of peace amidst
great secrecy benedetti received his
instructions from the French Foreign
Office on about 7 July 7:30 in the
evening the next day he attempted to
carry them out and I would like to tell
you a little bit about that one Edward
count Vincent benedetti ambassador
extraordinaire and Minister
Plenipotentiary
to the King of Prussia boarded the train
dens from bill baud shortly before 8
o'clock on the morning of 8 July 1870 he
must have been greatly anxious over the
consciousness of his own importance for
the mission he was about to undertake
was one of the most sensitive and
difficult diplomatic assignments of all
time he was the bearer of a message of
supreme importance from a French
government whose Foreign Minister was
singularly averse to negotiations he had
been a few days maybe even only hours to
secure Leopold's withdrawal the figure
to whom his efforts would be directed
was the King of Prussia a sovereign
whose writ
like that at his counterpart in France
ran unchallenged throughout the realm a
commander who had under his hand one of
the greatest engines of war the world
had ever known an army that was still
basking in the throes of the victory it
had won over Austria just four years
before and whose generals with multi at
their head were only too impatient for a
fresh trial of strength on the Rhine
finally he had to carry out his duties
while the king and his entourage were
buzzing with presentment over granel's
defiant speech of six July the news of
that declaration reached Em's the day
before and brought to the highest
intensity the resentment that had been
building against France since the crisis
began the situation into which benedetti
now stepped was in a word precarious the
German novelist Theodore Fontana has
drawn a marvelous little sketch of Em's
in those last days of June 1870 never it
seemed the city been more beautiful more
pristine or more composed mountain peaks
floated peacefully against skies in
which the bright blue of summer made way
for drifting clouds in the courtyard and
on the promenade sunshine buried with
brief gentle showers the spas waters
fairly sparkled and from all over Europe
from as far away as Russia the most
prominent royalty came to the city to
take its incomparable cures little
groups of passers-by assembled
periodically at the marketplace to see
the famous take their walks and gathered
hourly in this in the city square as
they had for centuries to watch the
saints make their appointed rounds in
the clock the town hall flowers music
laughing voices were
everywhere there were parties every
evening
amidst the shower bouquets and banquets
King with him the first it arrived at
the spa
on 20 June there for the next two weeks
free from the press of everyday business
he could do nothing but relax stroll
each morning in the gardens outside his
residence take tea with his British
relatives in the late afternoons and go
out nightly to watch the plays and
listen to the various concerts and
symphonies that were being performed in
his honor by 7 July all had changed the
quaint garb of the city appeared
positively Museum life detached from the
realities of the moment the days were
now tense Europe had taken its farewell
it seemed of nearly everything that ends
hallmarks represented the Grand Mall
declaration the first French bolli in
the war of words resounded across Europe
like the crack of doom there too
Russian ambassador to France seemed to
capture the spirit of the moment when
stepping off the train he said to one of
the Kings adjutant the devil is loose in
Paris it looks very much like war and it
did indeed it did and William the first
soon became alarm he had disliked the
idea of Leopold going to Spain all along
he thought to himself I'll have a word
with the boy and help withdraw but it
was not quite so simple
Leopold's like everyone else it seems
was on vacation in bavaria out of touch
with events and the king was forced to
deal with Leopold's father his name was
Carl and Tom
the confusion and the disorder did not
sit well with the king well in the first
was in difficulties after authorizing
Leopold to accept the throne of Spain
he was now called upon to retract that
authorization his personal dignity was
offended as well especially as the
French government had addressed him in
threatening terms in Parliament he'd
regret all the same he preserved the
moderate attitude did he regret giving
his personal consent or did he look with
alarm at the prospect of war between
France and Prussia probably a little of
both at any rate he did his best to
accommodate Benedetti what he seemed to
desire was that his self-esteem should
be considered and that he'd be given
time to work out arrangements but the
time was out of joint tired overcome by
the heat of midsummer he had come to a
mess to relax and take his mineral cures
instead he found himself weighed down by
the wearisome business of politics
telegrams were pouring in at the rate of
four or five and our audiences had to be
granted he could not see Queen Augusta
the endless consultations and fatiguing
diplomatic maneuvering had taken their
toll on his patience his Congeniality
his temper was short his emotion
sensitive his communication is conducted
in a hugger-mugger of haste and
confusion Williams mood turns sour
the French rulers were surrendering to
popular outcry and obstruction from
sigmaringen there was nothing silence
the letter that he had written to carl
anton on 6 july had been intended to
paint a clear picture of the
difficulties Leopold would face
King of Spain and thus make it easier
for him to pull out the sigmaringen
'he's had as yet showed not the
slightest willingness to do so bring him
the first theer that in the heated
atmosphere of the time nothing would
come of this intervention still as
resolve was unshaken he said to his wife
i will not spend a dollar to buy a vote
in the Cortes and a little later I hope
with all my heart that Leopold is not
elected king of Spain in the meantime
Benedetti could only report that the
Kings desire for a peaceful outcome was
unquestionable and that he was
redoubling his efforts to contact his
cousins
the news of all these events fortified
by a stupendous volume of rumor and
speculation had by 12 July created a
state of the highest uneasiness in Paris
Leopold's refusal to stand down had
brought grandma's temperature to a fever
pitch there were wild councils in the
chamber calling for immediate war the
Ryan could easily be crossed the
Prussian capital could be occupied by
the French in a matter of days the war
would end with the new llena in light of
these circumstances the leading officers
in the army were now given a greater
voice in the proceedings
on 12 July grandma talked with the
French commander said buff and was told
by him that war should begin at once
any delay would be disastrous in the
heat of the moment rumours of impending
Prussian mobilization we're flying thick
and fast in the journalistic and
diplomatic centers of the city
unfortunately such rumors found credence
in the highly most highly placed and
influential of the French ministers and
the tension continued to build and build
and build but a great event occurred on
12 July Leopold
renounced the throne of Spain or rather
his father renounced it for him the
story of this episode how it took place
one of the most dramatic and point in
European history is in the book and I'm
not going to read about that what I want
to do is to tell you instead the effect
that Leopold's withdrawal had on the
French and the answer was is it wasn't
good enough for them
the French therefore made another demand
that William the first apologized to
France for having started the candidacy
though he had really little to do with
it not only must he apologized he must
promise that Leopold will never again
run for the throne of Spain
well these demands these new French
demands set off alarm bells all over
Europe no one was more alone than one
emilio viscount de Van Osten the Foreign
Minister of Italy whose papers I read in
Florence in the summer of 1999 and who
strikes me as being one of the great
unsung heroes of the franco-prussian war
I would like to close my readings by
telling you what discount they then owes
the thought of these French demands he
wrote to a friend on 12 July it is our
duty to point out earnestly to the
French government the responsibilities
it would assume and the embarrassed
it would cause it's best friends at the
precipitated complications and refused
to allow time for a solution to majora
in London Madrid and Florence that such
a solution is possible we believe most
true let us hope that the French
government abides by the advice of its
well-wishers and does not allow the
excitement and bellicosity of mobs to
impel it into a catastrophe the likes of
which we are not likely ever to witness
again these observations lend to the
pattern of discontent the gnosis hopes
and strivings in July 1870 a dignity
that does not flow from the bare record
of his dealings with the European rulers
it is comforting to note but the
qualities that brought this from Devon
Austin albeit through Grievous thoughts
and many allusions to perceptions of
this order have not escaped the notice
of statesmen and historians and have not
failed to influence by and large
favorably their judgment of at least a
portion of the actions he undertook and
this is only as it should be
anyone who observe them at all
sympathetically during those brief but
crowded days could reasonably have
concluded that he was teetering on the
edge of a major personal tragedy from
the effects of which one suspects he was
never fully to recover all his efforts
to mobilize support for peace had failed
his strenuous at times frantic appeals
to France
to defuse the crisis before the guns
went off in the lives of tens of
thousands sank in blood on a portion of
the press it is true and on some of the
diplomatic community in Florence
Viscount daven Ulster had some palpable
influence but his counsel was brushed
off by Paris the fateful decisions on
the Hohenzollern question were made
either in total disregard or in direct
defiance of his stated views and it is
no exaggeration to say that no serious
effort was ever made by Graham or the
French to see in here and way on their
merits the details of the case he sought
to present the heavy measure of
frustration and disappointment that
Visconti the nose to faced was in a
large part of his own making Fortas
doubt he ever fully understood the depth
and the power of the forces arrayed
against him not only in France but at
home in Italy as well politically weak
to the point of debility physically weak
to the point of exhaustion supported
only by a dwindling band of cabinet
ministers and journalists less
thoughtful less knowledgeable less
moderate than he reviled harass undercut
by his own King he yet continued to
believe that somehow the great French
ship of state would write itself and
that he would realize the object of his
exalted hopes and then came granel's
fiery speech to the French chamber on 15
July which meant for him worlds and
but it would be wrong to end the story
at this point here as so often it was
the totality of the human personality
rather than its partial manifestations
that was of greatest importance in light
of his appreciations this Dante von
Osten cannot be permitted to depart the
stage of Europe 1870 without a word of
recognition for the efforts he put forth
with such untiring dedication to end the
franco-prussian crisis at its Apogee nor
can he be denied posthumously a pang of
sympathy for the unfeeling rejection to
which those efforts were subjected by
those who had events taken a different
turn which surely not had been averse to
sharing the credit for his achievement
among the tragedies that attended the
period of July 1870 there was none aside
from with him the first and benedetti
that bore so great a poignancy and
dignity as his well how did it all turn
out read the next book
now um Fergus County Minister and Italy
not all that badly this don't even hasta
would live until 1909 as a result of the
franco-prussian war Italy's capital
would be transferred from Florence to
Rome where it is today the French came
off much worse they lost the war
Napoleon's Empire was overthrown and a
republic was set up henceforth France
would have president's not kings or
Queens or emperors or Empress's a
situation that exists today Prosser our
friend would absorb these states of
southern Germany Germany would become
United and remain that way until 1945
William the first would become emperor
of Germany not King of Prussia and
Bismarck not Prussian Prime Minister but
German Chancellor it was Bismarck who
having laid on three wars drew a
striking moral from the franco-prussian
war to have no more Wars
I think we have a question we just
everybody
thank you very much very very
interesting David I'd like for you to uh
to comment a little bit more about the
fact that it matters who's uh who's in
charge and these personalities that they
as I understand it your premise is that
they they shaped history and that
history did not shape those
personalities would you come in a little
bit more about that well had there been
other people in power at the time of
this book clearly uh there would have
been no war there was a peace party to
some extent in France there were people
in Germany who wanted Bismarck's job uh
there was the determination on the part
of Bismarck to force the King of Prussia
to get his way had someone other than
Bismarck been in power it's doubtful
whether that would have would have taken
place and it strikes me that that today
anyway we had historians many of them
are prominent historians who say that
personalities and wills and so forth of
the individual and the long run of
things don't make a lot of difference
and here had it not been for the
determination of Bismarck to get this
man on the throne of Spain had it not
been for the fiery denunciations of
Prussia that were issued by the French
Foreign Minister events may well have
taken a different turn but you're quite
right um the book is meant to show that
people make a difference in history it's
a somewhat remote or tired theory on I
think it's argued rather strongly here
but it's encountered some opposition
along the way I should say among less
perceptive reviewers than I want
of with him I'm arguing might want now
thank you very much yeah David do you
think that there is any kind of
historical impact from the
franco-prussian war on relations between
France and Germany today and do you
think also perhaps there are any modern
parallels with the situation then yeah
I'm hard put to give a an answer to that
question today obviously the friendship
between France and Germany is the
hallmark of Europe whereas in this
period the the antagonism between the
two countries was the hallmark
I suppose if I had to give you an answer
it would be something like this Europe
today is supposed to be empty of
nationalities feelings there's that
there was the the iya iya au the euros
and so forth if that is the case and it
is I think it tips the scales a little
bit in the favor of Napoleon the third
who was who envisaged in his writings a
United States of Europe now it's true
that his dreams in AH his ambitions too
to have this come about were full of
contradictions but uh what did the
what's the relationship between the
franco-prussian war and the Europe of
today hmm I'd say that it's the reverse
of what it was at the time I was writing
about and now we have comedy we are Co
MIT one a comedy and and good feeling
before we had antagonism and
embitterment and that antagonism and
embitterment was not change until 1945
in the Second World War
no more questions I've answered them all
huh yes David could you tell us a little
bit more about your travels in Europe
and gathering all this information oh
yes um well I traveled to Flitz the five
or six countries their names almost
escaped me right now for Great Britain
France Germany Austria Italy and what
there is there are the records that have
not been published of the dealings of
the countries on and I was able in some
cases through the help of very generous
people because I said the custodians the
people who bring books to you and so
forth are extremely kind I was able with
their help to microfilm and take notes
on some important documents which I used
too as some of the material for this
book also helped if I may say so by this
passion I have four languages I'm
determined never to set foot in the
country unless I can say a three or four
words in the in the mother tongue I
often butcher it but I think yeah when
you can say I need this book or thank
you or you know I'll need this right
away you're very kind to do this goes a
long way and so that's the hopefully an
answer to your question the book could
not have been written without the those
documents yes sir
David just one last question what was
what was the position of the the other
big player in Europe was supposedly one
of the strongest countries in the world
was Britain what was what was their
position on the franco-prussian war the
British were neutral they had they had
this lot while they heard of Waterloo
they had this long antagonism towards
France which went back to Napoleon's
uncle Napoleon the first after the
French were defeated the government in
France the new government tried very
much to get the British and the Russians
IMed and the Austrians and the Italians
to come in on their side
British remain neutral after the Crimean
War which I've written about they had
more or less turned their back on Europe
and they felt Napoleon the third was a
figure that really I couldn't be trusted
and they were better off really without
him yes sir yes uh are you working on a
another project now yes sir um I had
done made the terrible mistake
my end did this finished this book of
taking back to the library the hundred
books one each day I had taken out to
write it and we have a car system which
I think tracks delinquencies but mine
was never done ever
no more by one day and the editor called
me and said well everybody has reviewed
this said that there's a the problem is
it's good but you haven't told the whole
story of the war so why don't you do
that
we'll be happy to publish it so oh my
god I think these books out of the
library it's gonna take six months to do
that and but your question does go to uh
uh one of the arguments in the book I
could not have written that had it not
been a for Berkeley for the people with
whom I work and also for the library I
think I've taken we often I do take it
for granted they're able to get books at
a minutes notice if they don't have them
on their shelves themselves I cannot say
about more cannot praise the staff of
DOE library to Hilah and interlibrary
loan yes sir yes
Thanks
it clearly you make an argument that the
agents that make a difference and I'm
wondering if you elaborate or develop
how the potential of the individuals is
mediated with the social cultural
setting of the times for example Graham
oh he had he could make it his
impassioned pleas found a receptive
audience it would seem I'm wondering if
you develop that in the book could you
explain the question well I'm just
wondering you're making cause argument
that agents make a difference and I
don't have a problem with that but I'm
wondering how it mediates with cultural
and social settings and with the French
minister como is that that's correct
he made an impassioned plea and he
wanted to go to war he was a very
principled actor in this story but if
his desires found the potential it seems
to me the French people were receptive
to is pleased to go to war or there was
something about the setting that made
his pleas more receptive or his position
more receptive I'm wondering if your
meaty if you analyze how that the
potential of that actor was mediated by
the setting well there was of course in
Europe of the 19th century we had the
growth of nationalism I were the King
other words in the 16th 16th century or
the 15th century the king would declare
war or win that's an exaggeration they
could not do that in 19th century no you
had to take into account the feelings of
the population and it's true that
grandma was as was Bismarck was very
much a product of his own of his own
background and it's also true that
Napoleon the third are developed on in
this I've go into this in some detail
polling methods to take the pulse of the
of the people so I think to answer your
question that there was a public opinion
make the decision or the public opinion
on
with public opinion the result of it I'm
not sure but and I'm not sure I've
answered your question but definitely
the opinions of the people had to be
considered and the French newspapers
especially more so than in Prussia where
they were more or less controlled not
totally but more or less the French
newspapers were full of sensationalist
and bellicose arguments and words going
to war and whether the ministers created
that is I think they did or whether they
were created by the population isn't is
an argument among historians of the
franco-prussian war my first professor I
had at the University of Pennsylvania
his name was Lynn M case and who's
mentioned a great deal in this book and
whom I revere made a study of this and
concluded that it was popular pressure
that drove the French to war ah he would
turn over in his grave if he realized
that I reached the opposite conclusion
but and one of his students just
reviewed the book on the internet by the
way you can look that up if you want to
oh not not unfavorably I'm happy to say
yes Beulah how are you I didn't
understand what you were seeing
Graham Oh Brammo oramel and I didn't
could you clarify the name GRA mo NT in
French grandma uh uh-huh
hidden list I didn't know who you were
talking about I thought you were saying
Brammo and i was saying well who is
grandma and how does he relate to what
you were saying is and then the
gentleman asks oh I saw it then it came
across another way who is he was he of
the people was the other kingdom was he
of hierarchy was he for the populace was
the militant I mean you just kind of
threw it out there and I'm in limbo with
him okay
bear with me um
grandma was a noble he was the
descendant of one of the highest names
in French history his ancestry could be
traced back to the 15th 16th century to
the time of the French civil wars now
there were on the opposite side of
grandma people who came from backgrounds
or just as high as his who were argued
the other way but he's not the most
appealing of personalities in my opinion
and I I may at times be a little hard on
him but I think he deserves the the the
treatment he gets I'd almost argue that
if he had not done some of the things he
did there would have been no
franco-prussian war I don't go that
almost I go that far on the book but not
quite okay